Sound is a wave that we perceive with
our ears.
It makes our favorite music, and it keeps
us out of danger, but it's so much more than
that!
Hey everybody!
Thanks for checking out Dnews today.
I'm Trace.
Now listen up!
Sound is extremely powerful.
It's made of
invisible waves of energy passing through
substances -- ground, water, air -- particle
to particle.
The human ear can perceive these
waves as long as their frequencies are between
20Hz and 20,000Hz.
Anything above or below
that, we can't hear but they're
still there because these waves contains
energy.
And with enough
ding, you can make these waves do some
incredible things.
Outside of medical technology, like
ultrasound, one of the most commonly
known ways to make sound do something
is by breaking a glass.
This works only
when the sound wave is at the exact same frequency
as the object you're shooting at.
If you gently flick a wine glass with your
fingernail, you will hear its frequency.
Match that tone and turn the volume up!
Way way up!
To like a eleven!
And that glass
will probably break.
Also within the range of hearing is sound
levitation.
This is way cooler than breaking stuff if
you ask me.
Sound levitation has been around for years,
but until recently,
we couldn't do much with the stuff once
it was levitated.
It just hung there in the air.
Thanks to advances at a Swiss University called
ETH Zurich,
we can not only levitate stuff, but we can
move it around, adjusting floating fluids.
This works by using the energy in the sound
waves.
In this apparatus, the energy waves reflect
back and forth so quickly,
they form what's called a standing
wave or a specific point where the energy
from the sound can hold
an object in mid-air.
Think it like these silly executive desk toys.
The ball in the middle, that's the
standing wave.
The thing that they just figured out is
how to move the stuff once it's levitated.
Now they can use this system to manipulate
liquids combining and separating them,
all without touching them with human
hands, which is immediately applicable
to drug manufacturers.
That's kinda cool.
These energy waves can do a lot of other stuff
too.
The LRAD, or long-range acoustical
devices, is a weapon that shoots sound.
It's like a sonic death
ray, but without the death part.
It can produce so much sound that you feel
physical pain.
Like
160 decibels.
That's loud.
Think NASA
rocket launch.
But it won't kill you.
It just really hurts.
Like a sonic hurt ray.
If you combine some those
technologies, sound can produce really
strange effects.
In the 1950s,
NASA the US Navy built a device
the produces ultra low frequencies or
ultrasonic sound.
If you pointed it at a person and set it
to 19Hz, people would have
vision problems and get spots and stuff
because 19Hz
is the resonant frequency of the human
eyeball.
Kinda like that wine glass example we talked
about.
If you turn the volume up, people
actually would have trouble breathing
because the low frequencies were
impacting the lungs like
energy waves.
And if you shot through the
ground, your skeleton would vibrate
causing nausea and joint pain.
So which of these sound inventions is your
favorite?
The levitating ones for drug
manufacturing, ultrasound or maybe one of
the ones that are used for EVIL?
Share your thoughts with us
and we'll see you next time on Dnews.